from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pringles in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk our smallest pringle size is a
40 gram tube
these come as a single tube as a box of
12.
or around the holidays we can get a
pringles christmas cracker which comes
with four
40 gram tubes in the us the smallest
portion of pringles you can get
is this a snack stack this 19 gram snack
stack
comes in units of 12
18. this is super weird 27
and
48 snack stacks
our next size is a 70 gram tube
we also have pringles in this grab and
go size which is 2.5 ounces or 71 grams
you can get them in single obviously
or in packs of 15. this isn't even the
biggest grab-and-go size apparently they
have a size as even bigger that's
74 grams or 2.5 ounces uh
i ate that on the way here i'm sorry and
then from there we go to a full-size
tube
which is 200 grams all flavors were the
same amount in the uk
in the us our regular tubes are actually
smaller
you get about 5.5 ounces per tube
but the flavor actually adds to the
weight here's an original
pringles and this is only 5.2 ounces
0.3 0.3 more for the flavor but the uk
stops the regular not here in the us
check it out the party tube
6.8 ounces of chip
right there seeing as the weights are so
similar we're going to count how many
pringles are in a uk regular tube versus
a us party stack tube to see who's
getting more
all right let's do it
oh yeah
yeah definitely gonna need a bigger tray
i might have to go into the table
this is going to be boring pringles they
don't break as easily
ah i have regularly eaten a whole tube
of pringles by myself
oh what what where here
this one i'm gonna eat them all instead
of putting them back in the cheek
it's taking all my willpower and that
snack on these as i'm doing it
[Music]
most people can't then swallow the whole
thing most people aren't me
not most people are party stack holds
roughly 104
pringles so it looks like a regular tube
in the uk contains around 92 pringles
how many can i get in my mouth at once
as well that's what i don't know without
like crunching them all up and breaking
them let me see if i can do ten nine
ten pringles but i'm gonna go with
thirteen lucky thirteen
[Music]
i'm gonna take i'm gonna take two off
[Music]
i do not have the mouth for pringles
apparently my proverbial hat off to you
the crown is yours
this right here is roughly 100 grams of
original salted
pringles chips in the u.s it contains
the following 535 calories
32.13 grams of fat 535.5 milligrams of
sodium
and 57.12 grams of carbs
i know you can't tell but this is like
two-thirds of the tube
right and it contains almost half of
your fat allowance for the day 100 grams
of original pringles in the uk contains
the following
514 calories 33 grams of fat 520
milligrams of sodium and 51 grams of
carbs that means our pringles have
slightly more fat than the us version
but almost half the saturated fat
in the u.s majority of the pringle
flavors have the same number of calories
as the original flavor but there are
some changes to some of the other
numbers
when you branch out a saltier sprinkle
is actually the salt and vinegar 100
grams of uk salt and vinegar is 40
of your daily allowance of sodium the
saltiest of the pringles in the us are
the buffalo ranch 100 grams of them
contain 999.6 milligrams of sodium
avoid avoid
what in the good god oh man
oh i can't believe the flavor in these
things i
i i gotta try that again
[Music]
oh my god these are so disgusting
this might be the worst thing i've
tasted on the show all the salt
for all the buffalo ranch in the factory
got condensed into one container
on accident and we bought it this is so
gross
in the uk original pringles contain the
following dehydrated potatoes
vegetable oils sunflower and corn rice
flour
wheat starch corn flour emulsifier e471
maltodextrin salt yeast extract yeast
powder
and color and natto original pringles in
the u.s contain
dried potatoes vegetable oil which is
corn cotton seed high oleic soybean oil
and or sunflower oil
g-germinated yellow corn flour corn
starch rice flour
maltodextrin mono and diglycerides salt
and wheat starch these are actually very
similar
the e471 in the uk is actually the same
as the mono and diglycerides used in the
us
just used by a different name the only
other notable changes
are the yeast used in the uk and the
fact that the uk colors its pringles
with a neto
an orange red food coloring but how much
different is the color
okay the longest ingredient list for a
classic pringle flavor in the uk is
prawn cocktail it contains
28 main ingredients likely with a lot
more because some of them aren't fully
disclosed like the flavorings and the
spices
now from what i can tell
the longest ingredients list for a
classic us flavor
is the cheddar and sour cream they
contain 32 main ingredients
along with a bunch of sub ingredients
takes a total of 40.
i'm not reading this out loud on that
list you'll see of course a couple
ingredients that you won't find in the
uk pringles namely
yellow number five and yellow number six
i'm wearing yellow number seven it's
always with the yellow stuff
these are also referred to as tartrazine
and sunset yellow there were two
chemicals highlighted by a study back in
2007 into links between hyperactivity
and food additives
the initial results suggested that there
was indeed a link between these
chemicals and hyperactivity
however since then the european food
safety authority has backtracked and
said that might not be the case
also in that study was red 40 aka allura
red which appears in the green's list
for the memphis barbecue
pringles and these the pizza pringles
foods using these chemicals in the uk
must still bear a warning to say that
they may have an adverse effect on
activity and attention in children
which means that most manufacturers will
just avoid using them wait has he always
been bald
yeah he's bald thought he had hair
no you're thinking of the guy from the
monopoly thing no wait look yeah hair
what the hell hair and no hair julius
pringle
what's going on dude is this weird this
is weird right hairgates2021
why does he have hair and someone on the
other ones
here are all the pringles you find in
the uk but not the us these are
most of the us exclusive pringles
cheddar and sour cream jalapeno
pizza honey mustard which sounds weird
oh no no
no oh this tastes like a mistake
someone screwed up on those that might
be the worst one the buffalo was just
too salty but that is the worst flavor
i mean this this stuff is made
for 13 year old gamers this is made to
sit
and consume while you're staring at a
flashing screen stimulus stimulus
stimulus like i'm in awe of how intense
these are
hey joe can i try one of those ranch
[Music]
pringles
it's quite quite splintered didn't
survive the journey i like that that's a
good pringle
i need to get these over here oh god
buffalo was a buffalo ranch yeah i'm not
eating these i'll skip those
hey it's the screamin dill pickle
what is going what is going on on this
label ship is wearing uh
goggles and a snorkel it would've been
better if the chip was just like
you know when you go and get a burger
and the fries
and they put that wedge of pickle on the
side and the pickles touching some of
the fries
and then those fries taste like pickles
this is a whole flavor of that
who wants that over here we've got prawn
cocktail
now this is really popular in the uk for
those who aren't familiar with prawn
cocktail there is no prawn in here
what this is is the sauce that you would
normally serve with a prawn cocktail
it's just a kind of like tangy tomatoey
pringle and personally i'm a big fan
then moving on to this one which is
paprika flavor
in this menacing looking black fiery can
we have hot and spicy pringles but
they're basically just pringles flavored
with some jalapeno extract along with
some other peppers as well
i don't smell too spicy cheers
i'm getting like a little bit of garlic
a little bit of tomato
not getting any heat though people
insist on calling things hot and spicy
and then make things that really aren't
that hot and spicy next up we've got
smoky bacon pringles personally i love
these but i will say if you eat one they
stay on your breath for about two weeks
regardless of how many times you brush
your teeth then we've got some peri-peri
pringles
now if you've seen the nana's episode
you'll know that as a country the uk is
obsessed with prairie prairie chicken
and pringles have capitalized on that
with some
prairie prairie chicken flavoured
pringles according to the uk pringles
website you should also be able to get
steak pringles and thai sweet chili
pringles but none of the supermarkets
that i visited actually had any
now both the us and the uk you can get
spicier pringles in the u.s that are
called
scorching how hot could this possibly be
scorching
chili lime not that hot
actually yeah i know instead of
scorching our spicy pringle range is
actually called
sizzlin this is fun to say and it comes
in a kick and sour cream exclusive or as
an extra hot cheese and chili exclusive
which unfortunately we weren't able to
find today
it's sizzle time this one sour cream is
a strange one because sour cream is the
thing you're supposed to use to like
cool the heat down
definitely attack your tongue a bit more
than the hot and spicy ones did still
not like mind-blowingly hot
also in the u.s we got these wavy
pringles which look like they're just
straight ripping off ruffles
classic salted applewood smoked cheddar
fire roasted jalapeno
sweet and spicy barbecue and something
to do with the video game hi-lo
hilum and something to do with the video
game halo
moa burger all this is for children this
is all for children
we might not have wavy pringles but we
do have rice fusion pringles these are
pringles which are made with rice and
inspired by asian flavors
indian tandoori chicken masala flavour
and a japanese katsu curry flavor
we're supposed to also be able to get
malaysian red curry flavor a peking duck
and hoisin sauce flavor
and a bbq teriyaki flavor the last
exclusive pringles i want to talk about
are the original lightly salted yeah
perfect this is how potato chips should
taste like ah
yeah unfortunately pringles lightly
salted equals normal everywhere else
it's so bizarre it's like hair and no
hair
why they made that choice